the controversial self-styled Syrian
rescue group the white helmets drew
focus on a closed United Nations meeting
on Thursday diplomats are said to be
divided over the group's possible
removal from post-war Syria the white
helmets have been accused of links to
extremists and working alongside the
al-nusra terrorist group they deny the
claims insisting their instead a civil
rescue group an associate editor from
the new site 21st century wired.com
visited the group's headquarters in
Syria Venessa Billy will be out in full
what she found on Saturday's edition of
going on the ground here in RT for now
here's a snippet we entered a
functioning white helmet center now what
was interesting is the presumption by
those white helmets was that because I
was British I was sympathetic to their
cause so the conversation immediately
turned to their funding the fact that
made a rescue and rights Allah the head
of the white helmets had turned off the
funding to this group in the last six
months funding previously by the way
that each individual working for the
white helmets received one hundred and
fifty dollars a month that was that
information was given to me the white
helmets who left with the special
expedition by led by Israel and crossed
through the connector security fence
into the occupied Syrian territory of
the Golan Heights so into Israeli
occupied territory and then also Jordan
knows what I was told around fifty
percent were actually terrorist leaders
nusra front leaders and Isis fighters
coming in from the yon or Faison of
those of course some have been resettled
now in the UK there is huge secrecy over
those that have entered the UK and where
they are being resettled they told me
that while they were not affiliated to
nusra front despite the fact that their
centre was actually in a nusra front
complex that nusra front headquarters
were directly next door to the white
helmet centre that I visited and they
told us that while they had no
affiliation to nusra front it was very
likely that every other white helmet
group in Syria did have a variation to
nusra front well
by nusra front militants but of course
they had no affiliation and as such they
should be considered for funding and
financing by the British government
[Music]
you